we have yet another possible major
bombshell in the Trump Russia scandal
u.s. European and Arab officials are
telling The Washington Post that the UAE
arranged a secret meeting in January
between Blackwater founder Eric Prince
who happens to be the brother of Trump
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos and a
Russian close to Vladimir Putin to
establish a back-channel line of
communication between Moscow and
president-elect Trump the meeting took
place around January 11th nine days
before the inauguration in the
Seychelles Islands in the Indian Ocean
it's not clear what was discussed but
the UAE agreed to broker the meeting in
part to explore whether Russia could be
persuaded to curtail its relationship
with Iran including in Syria and also to
look at reducing American sanctions on
Russia this once again correlates
precisely with the publicly known
timeline of events about the Trump
Russia scandal Blackwater's Eric Prince
as we've heard from Sean Spicer had no
formal role in the Trump campaign but he
reportedly presented himself as an
unofficial envoy for Trump to
high-ranking Emiratis involved in
setting up this meeting with the Putin
confidence and once again Eric Prince
was a major donor to Trump and is the
brother of Betsy DeVos who we were
wondering you've got this completely
unqualified person nominated to
Secretary of Education we know that her
family has donated a lot of money and oh
by the way it's now alleged that her
brother was involved in creating back
channels directly between the Trump team
and Vladimir Putin this sheds a lot of
light on what Betsy DeVos was doing
there and it is yet another piece in the
growing web of connections between Trump
and Russia now Sean Spicer was asked
about this Pat what did Sean Spicer say
meaningless answer quote we are not
aware of any meetings and Eric Prince
had no role in the transition number one
there are many meetings which have been
proven to have taken place that Sean
Spicer has denied being aware of so that
tells us zero and number two nobody's
saying that
Eric Prince had a formal role in the
transition there iiib
at this point we can't believe a word
Sean Spicer says we certainly can't I
mean I'm just kind of concerned that
this roundabout means of communication
is enough to create some sort of
plausible deniability because it's not
as if Trump and Putin were directly
communicating it seems yeah so we have
to see if his top campaign officials
were in contact and oftentimes as we've
learned from Watergate the cover-up
could be more indicative of wrongdoing
than the actual crime itself you're not
wrong but I'm struggling to see how we
can have this much smoke without
eventually finding fire this is yet
another once removed connection and I
know what you're saying Pat about
plausible deniability but we're talking
about a once removed connection between
the Secretary of Education and Russia
which is another angle
are there any Trump cabinet members
either that who are not either directly
or at most with one layer of separate
separation connected to Russia and
there's another connection here remember
that story from a week or two ago about
the Alpha Bank server connecting to a
Trump Organization server and to a
server owned by the DeVos family run
company spectrum which is a medical
facility chain led by Betsey Davis's
husband at the time we were sort of
confused like okay the Russian bank
server was connecting to a Trump
Organization server but then second on
the list was a server owned by spectrum
this company that is run by Betsy Davos
as husband this could also start to
explain that it is yet another link in
these previously unexplained links
between Trump Russia and really really
sketchy companies this is an insane
amount of smoke where the Trump
administration continues to insist
there's no fire whatsoever and I'm sure
Trump would be more than willing to fire
Betsy DeVos if he has to just blame the
whole thing on her as he did with
Michael Flynn yes which hopefully will
backfire in terms of Flynn if he does
indeed end up testifying to what it is
that he knows we don't know if you will
this is crazy folks this is growing by
the day you can discuss this with me on
Twitter I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show